foreign
so I think Terminator 2 is not only one
of the greatest sequels ever made but
it's also one of the best action movies
of all time I think when we look back on
James Cameron's Legacy that this will
probably be the movie that gets
considered as Masterpiece why Terminator
is a classic aliens was outstanding yeah
and the abyss though not that popular
was still a brilliant film how about
Terminator 2 feels like it's a director
pulling on everything he'd learned on
those films and it feels like the
perfect movie that brings it all
together throughout this video we're
gonna be going through the film and
breaking it down scene by scene to talk
about every aspect of it this contains
Easter eggs hidden details and also
making of trivia that will hopefully
help you appreciate the movie even more
know now why you cry now back in the 90s
the film was a worldwide phenomenon and
for a good part of the decade it was
everywhere you looked kids today yeah
you don't understand but back in the
decade it was fine to have all right
movies marketed towards selling toys I
had to Terminator where you moved the
arm and the chest pops off and there was
also this crazy clay thing where you
could put flesh over a toy Terminator
created
Twitter I'm back
spawn video games a big Blockbuster ride
that ran for 20 years and it's the only
Terminator Farm to be nominated for
Oscars it won for the six it was up for
the getting best maker best sound best
sound effects editing and best visual
effects the Oscar goes
Gene Warren Jr and Robert scotak
Terminator two Judgment Day looking back
I think that this is the film where
stuff really started to shift from
practical to CG and it handles both
brilliantly still holding up today at
James Cameron these days is of course
known as the king of the box office but
back in the 80s and 90s that just wasn't
the case when this was put into
production it was said to be the most
expensive movie ever made and all the
reports said there was no way it would
make its money back as we've seen this
is something Cameron's done time and
time again but this was really the first
film where he cemented himself and also
his returns back in 91 this took over
half a billion at the box office which
30 years later would still be a pretty
solid run adjusted for inflation it's a
massive massive movie and back then it
was the third highest grossing film of
all time now if you've watched our
breakdown on the first Terminator movie
then you'll know that we talked about
some mid-scrapped elements originally
Cameron wanted two Terminators to go
back with the second being a liquid
metal one who could shape-shift and
change States He also wanted to have a
moment where the heroes try to take down
cyberdyne and this was in order to avert
the coming War Cameron felt like the
technology wasn't there at the time to
do either and that adding those aspects
in would simply bog the whole thing down
however after working on the abyss and
all the liquid stuff in that he realized
that the tech had caught up to where
they could do the T-1000 and so things
were put in place during 1989 with
writing beginning the air after in 1990
diverging from the science fiction
slasher that made that first film so
memorable they instead wanted to focus
on themes of family with a Terminator
becoming a main character co-writer
William Wisher Jr originally thought
this was a joke but as they did the
treatment he started to fall in love
Wisher actually appears in the film
during the mall and he's the guys taking
photographs when Arnie's on the ground
wisha also appeared in that very first
film and he was the cop who had his car
stolen by Arnie Cameron later said that
these are actually the same character
and this is why in the mall he seems
like he recognizes him and realizing how
expensive that the T-1000 and could be
Cameron came up with other initial
Concepts to make the movie cheaper one
of the ideas was that two t800s would be
sent back with both parts being played
by Arnold Schwarzenegger I'll be back
however wishes said this was boring and
they also considered using super
Terminators before going all in on the
liquid one the pitch was at the T-1000
would play a policeman the entire time
which would allow it to move around and
detect it and ask questions out in
public Cameron actually had a lot of
criticism of the police and them
overstepping the mark made big news at
the time still does today and he said
that being in a position of power like
that can make someone lose compassion
and become like a machine on the other
side of this you have the T800 who
begins to learn emotions and over time
he becomes more and more human you also
have Sarah too and Linda Hamilton's a
far cry from how she appeared in that
first film able to [__] a shotgun with
one hand she was voted the most
desirable woman at the MTV Movie Awards
back in 1991. Sarah becomes like the
Terminator herself at one point and she
desperately hunts down Dyson to kill him
so he can't affect things in the future
she has a muscle-bound body wears
sunglasses as well and fires without
Mercy on him and his home she's very
much killing Skynet before it can be
born which of course Rifts on that plot
device used in the first film however
she too regains her Humanity after
coming face to face with him and there's
so many well thought out things
happening with their character I love
the scene in which Sean thinks she's
going to hug him but all she's doing is
checking for wounds to make sure he's
okay Sarah just sees him as a savior
that she has to raise up for War and the
Terminators seem as an asset to either
kill or protect Jon doesn't really have
any parental figures when we first meet
him and even though there's the foster
parents they don't see him for who he is
he too goes in a Big Arc and finally
gains the dad he's never had which also
makes her ending become even more
soul-destroying now as for that ending
well depending on what version you get
you're gonna get a slightly different
one the films be one of the most
re-released movies of all time and you
can probably find countless different
versions and formats featuring different
scenes and endings it's been released on
VHS LaserDisc which Cameron was a big
supporter of DVD Blu-ray and 4K Blu-ray
2. the last version was absolutely
terrible and Cameron got a lot of [__]
for how bad he messed up that transfer
so what I'm gonna do for this video is
go to the Skynet edition Blu-ray which
is the longest version of the film that
we currently have it's so secretive
right that when you put the Blu-ray in
and press play you have to enter a code
from the back of the box in order to
watch the film that contains the ending
with the older Sarah in the park and
she's looking over John who's now become
a senator this of course plays on the
nightmare that she has throughout the
film and it shows that the group have
managed to avert Judgment Day there were
also plans to include a young Carl
riccia but Sarah knew that she wouldn't
be able to talk to him and regretfully
she watched him pass over this part was
cut as it raised too many questions
about how Jon was still alive and so on
and so forth however come the end of
Dark fate they doing include Grace there
so yeah they did kind of adapt it from
this ending and then build it into that
now the original ending has a shot of a
road with Sarah saying hopefully humans
can learn to love each other because of
a machine a Terminator can learn the
value of human life maybe we can too
there are some versions where we
continue this shot and then the camera
pans up to show the building of
cyberdyne systems this should at the end
comes from earlier in the film and it
happens when they drive out of the
location now this tease that Judgment
day was always down the road and it sort
of builds off the back of the ending of
the first film Cameron was going back
and forth over how to handle it and just
two days before the premiere he decided
on the one we got it's kind of a bit you
poison at this point and the Terminator
timeline's so messy I don't think anyone
can be mad personally I prefer the idea
that they managed to stop Judgment day
and we ended the franchise after T2 and
lived happily ever after salvation is
good I suppose but the other difference
is in the longer Curts are that Michael
Bean cameos is Kyle and he acts as a
sort of regarding vision for Sarah we
also get Jon teaching the Terminator to
smile and also spend time with the
dysons which has him deciding to go and
make Hoovers that's a joke yeah but
there's also more scenes with the T-1000
however I'll talk about them later on
because there's lots of details in them
anyway I don't think that the Skynet
Edition is essential and it's mainly
more scenes for people who watch the
movie several times I think Cameron
tends to do brilliant Cuts first time
round and most of his directors Kurtz
are just a couple of extra scenes it's
not something like Batman v Superman
where the directors cut sorts out the
issues and makes the film vastly better
in my opinion either way we begin like
how the Skynet Edition ends with a focus
on kids playing in the park this is an
upbeat way to start things but as we go
on the scene quickly shifts transported
to a war zone we see a future battle
playing out and cut to the devastation
that's been left in skynet's Wake this
is actually filmed in a demolished Steel
factory in LA with a burnout cause being
provided by Universal back in 1989
rental employees set by to the Studio's
back law and they kept all the cars and
bikes to be used the air later here we
are in 2029 A.D and cut to destroyed
playground lidded with Twisted Metal in
skulls at this point we hear three
billion human lives ended on August 29
1997.
now the Soviet Union's first detonation
of an atomic bomb happened on the same
day in August 1949 and Nixa of course
what's been used to bring down the
planet instantly we get the subtext of
who's in control here with a metallic
Terminator but crushing a human skull
below it a blue tints added to the
screen purple lasers like the sky and
Cameron uses these colors later on to
foreshadow what's to come for Miles
Dyson later takes the chip out he goes
into a metallic steel blue room and we
can see the color purples used to act
here as a light he also stares at the
Almond purple light his face showing how
these two moments are intrinsically
connected Terminators walk the land with
Hunter killers in the sky and we get a
return of the shot where the tread
tracks Roll On Top Of Skulls a clear
note of the first film was then
introduced to John Connor and learned
that two more things have been sent back
to the past as before the resistance was
able to send a lone Warrior a protector
for John at this point we get the
incredible title sequence which holds
some symbolism too centered around the
playground this of course haunts Sarah's
dreams and we see for animal rides lined
up side by side Cameron said this was
supposed to represent the four horsemen
of the apocalypse which are often shown
in flames in their fictional depictions
lastly the machine comes fourth and
burns Inside the Fire foreshadowing the
fate of the T800 at the end now from
here we go to the 90s and watch Arnie
coming in and this is purposely supposed
to reflect the original's opening moment
if you checked out our breakdown then
you'll know we talked about its arrival
and how they purposely did the opposite
when Reese finally came in The
Terminator came down with Precision
whereas re-slammed off the floor and it
murdered people publicly whereas he ran
in hit this is something that they do
here to trick us with a Twist and to
make us think the t-1000s the good guy
in the film now I watched all the
special features when writing out this
script and Unfortunately they spoiled a
Twist in the trailer however I think had
you not seen this then it would have
been a great surprise and they actually
built the opening as a great bait and
switch we start off with the t800s
scanning over the area which mimics how
it did it in that very first film only
goes to the biker bar where we see him
beating people up whereas the T-1000
hides in the shadows and silently moves
about now no offense to Robert Patrick
if you're watching this but you're
nowhere near as built this already was
and he reflects how thin and worry Kyle
was back in that initial movie that gave
us a David and Goliath situation that we
think's the same case here too and we of
course have the roles that they take on
in the past the T800 stressed in leather
just like how he was in that first film
whereas the 1000 being a cop makes it
seem like he's the good guy the car of
course says to protect and serve and
they even do some clever things with the
score as well when the T800 searching
for Jon we get a repeat of the theme
from the first film which is used once
more to make us think that he's the
villain
all right
however this changes when the T-1000
makes his move and from this point
onwards we get more heroic music
foreign
Vision whereas the T-1000 we never get
that view now this is to trick us into
thinking that he's human as if we saw it
from his point of view we'd instantly
see that he's a machine now that vision
is something it has some nice details in
it and we can catch some cool little
text when the machine makes its
assessment when the biker blows smoke in
his face it actually scans the chemicals
of it now we can see that there's
Carthage in Vapor there's no particular
damage and along the left hand side it
lists the chemicals inside it finally we
see him set defense systems to Max which
happens just before he says I need your
clothes your boots and your motorcycle
thrown beside a Pepsi sign we'll see a
lot of that in the film because the
movie needed a lot of product placement
to pay for its big budget Ani also
throws one of the bikers out onto a car
and we can later see him in the back
when Arnie takes the bike also just
probably gonna keep saying Arnie because
having to record T800 800 times it's
bloody gonna kill me now when he's
outside he takes that guy's shotgun and
sunglasses which he still wears at night
even though it's dark
[Music]
he also doesn't put the light on the
bike when he's driving around and this
is because the Terminator comes packing
night vision now according to reports in
the movie The Studio yet they actually
wanted to cut this scene because the
budget had ballooned up to 88 million
from its original 75. James Cameron yeah
as per usual told the studio to [__] off
saying that only a studio guy would want
to cut this scene now the shoot went on
for a couple of nights and apparently
during one of the takes a woman walked
into the bar and aware of what was going
on she asked what was happening and
Arnold jokingly said it was a stripper
night and this was then brought over to
the third film without opening on a
stripper night you close talk to the
hand anyway across town we see Robert
Patrick coming in and he's easily one of
the best villains in film history now as
you mentioned last time Arnie spent a
lot of time before filming firing guns
and this was so that he could use the
weapon without ever blinking this is
something that Patrick did as well and
throughout the entire film he never
closes his eyes he also did a couple of
extra things to take it up a notch and
he learned to fire with both his right
and left hands because machines would be
ambidextrous he also never breeds in the
film even when he's running any practice
sprinting with his mouth closed while
breathing through his nose now when it
comes to the final fight he also doesn't
swear whereas on he does because he's
made of living tissue another detail
that you might not notice is that the
gun that's part of his uniform isn't
something he actually uses or fires in
the film what do you mean what do you
what do you mean
what do you mean now let me explain this
yeah he grabs one at the start but then
unloads it later on however the gun
stays in that whole step even though
it's empty all the other weapons that he
uses in the film are ones that he grabs
from other people so I don't actually
think that that's really a real gun he
gets blown up and turns into liquid
before walking out the fire so there's
no way that the Gunner could actually be
real after turning into the floor he
then turns into the guard and thus the
gun couldn't have come with him while he
was the floor so he had to grab it from
the God we later discover that he can't
make complex weapons like firearms and
thus all the weapons he has have to be
taken from someone however to complete
the luck he had part of his body morph
into one and the one at his side was
just part of the costume now as he uses
the cop computer we see Connor's name
pulled up and here we get a mention of
his mother along with his foster parents
we see their names Voit meaning that
John could have been called John Voit
which I don't know maybe maybe can run
through that and is a little joke we
also see his natural father's classes
being a because as we know Kyle Reese
traveled from the future anyway from
here we cut to Little John who's fixing
up his bike and in the background we can
hear some guns and roses
[Music]
they provided a song for the soundtrack
and this might be a reach here but the
Terminator letter shows up with a gun in
a box of roses
John also has a Public Enemy shirt and
the DJ from that was called Terminator
Rex I also think this might be a bit on
the nose in terms of subtext in the film
but Jon of course ends up becoming a
Public Enemy now he's purposely supposed
to be unlikable and just a little brat
who shuts down his foster dad because
he's got no strong Role Models he
doesn't know his father and his mother's
in a mental institution which is when we
cut across to her and see her working
out it's one of the biggest
Transformations there's ever been in a
film and it shows how much work Hamilton
put into this role run by Dr Silverman
he's become a series Mainstay and we see
that he's made a career off the back of
her and Rhys this is something that he
also mentioned last time this is great
stuff I could make a career out of this
guy you see how clever this part is how
it doesn't require Shredder proof
another scenes come full circle from
that first film across town we go to the
T-1000 arriving to ask where John is
this is a far cry from the first film in
which the Terminator burst in and his
politeness and personality instantly
throw us off however there's another
clue here that he's in fact a machine as
we can catch their dog barking faintly
in the background please could if you
were here took off on his bike this
morning so he could be anywhere do you
have a photograph of John when Annie
arrived in that initial movie there was
a dog barking there as well and as we
learned these were used to detect
Terminators now the T-1000 kills it
later on and this summer tips off the
T800 that they're actually dead now the
T800 uses the wrong name to suss him out
and I actually think this fixes the plot
hole later on I won't point the T-1000
catches Sarah Connor but for some reason
he let to live instead of just killing
her he gets her to call out to his
mother when he could have done the same
thing and dealt with one less person
protecting his only Target now I think
the dog name here that makes him realize
he doesn't know everything and if he
imitates her that he can still be caught
out potentially they could ask it
something it just doesn't know the
answer to unless she's kept alive just
in case he needs her as a hostage now
another great detail is that he only
ever fires his gun directly at Jon and
the character only kills in order to
make his way to him every time the
T-1000 fires a gun it only is aimed at
him with every bullet being meant for
him instead of someone else sorry Pepsi
guy you got in the way anyway from here
we go to John hacking in ATM and this
machine of course pops up later on when
they're breaking into cyberdyne great
bit of setup and payoff and we also get
the photo of Sarah Connor that John gave
to Reese when they met up in the future
and I said it's kept in a plastic wallet
here so I can survive the next 30 Years
and this explains why it lasted so long
into the future now in this special
edition Sarah sedated at this point and
she has a vision of Reese appearing to
her in a dream he's still guiding her
and at this point she very much tries to
become him when helping raise their son
here we can catch him in his clothes
from the first film including that green
trench coat which Sarah later wears when
they're breaking into cyberdyne this
shows how she's taken on his role in
this movie and he also says
on your feet Soldier
this is a line that pulls from the first
film
and this stream then transitions to her
at the park which is when the nuke goes
off now according to IMDb Cameron
actually got a letter from a lab
thanking him for the most realistic
depiction of a nuke going off that
they'd ever seen inspired by The Dream
she makes a move to try and get to see
her son and pretends that all the stuff
she said was simply made up however
seldom and Caesar is his Golden Goose
and as we pull the cameras back we see
her interview getting filmed with
several unlockers taking notes I don't
think he ever had any plans to move here
to minimum security and when he's giving
tours on just here you get the feeling
she would have failed this either way
now from here we also learn how
cyberdyne covered up the arm from the
first film and pretended it was never
found at the factory from the end we see
that Dyson's built a gigantic version of
the metal chip and he later uses a
snapped off bit for this for the
makeshift kill switch the chip itself is
actually based on the design of the
connection machine which itself was
created to try and make AI the room is
adorned with Dinosaurs as well so I'm
guessing this is coming us going extinct
with something from the sky and lastly a
lab tech runs over to him holding out a
delicious Pepsi and I just thought it
was funny how long he held it up on
screen man walked around the entire
compound just holding it to the camera
and I'm not mad at Cameron yeah pay for
the movie now he then leaves the guy and
walks into the next room and you can
catch Joe Morton actually holding the
door open so the cameraman can follow
him from here we get focus on the arm
which is what they salvaged last time
and we actually get a similar thing
happening at the end anyway both
Terminators tracked you under the
Galleria which is when we cut to him
playing on an arcade cabinet he's
busting out high scores on Iron Dome
Missile Command which is about stopping
nukes similar the plot that's in this
movie also a great little detail that
they do here is that they have only
walking through the crowd and then he
just shoulder barges into an old woman
her expression after this is absolutely
hilarious and I just love the idea of a
235 pound X bodybuilder shoulder barging
into an old woman in for a scene that
lasts a split second cancel it cancel
him now obviously this was part of the
film's plan to tricker so that it shows
the differences between the models the
t-1000s going around asking for
directions and being polite to kids
whilst Arnie's just bumping past people
to try and get to his Target again it
makes you think the T-1000 is a human
because it's stopping and asking things
Orizon he just seems like he's a robot
on a mission now I'd be remiss for not
mentioning Jon's little mate with the
ginger mullet but this man saves
Humanity by lying to the cops he also
actually does something that not many
other characters do and he says the line
hey bro I'm gonna get some quarters I'll
be back all right
yeah I'm pretty sure outside of Arnie
and Linda Hamilton that he's the only
one who gets that line though it might
not happen in dark fate as I've kind of
repressed that movie a bit in my memory
eventually the T-1000 lock sites with
him and we see a shift in the character
with him being the person now pushing
people out the way he shoves three kids
down including the ginger mullet one and
Patrick said he studied how sharks swim
to mimic their movement when walking
through a crowd running through the
corridors John comes face to face with
Ani which is where everything in the
film slows down and why this is
important is that it builds off some of
the motifs in that first film whenever
the Terminator assassinated someone in
the first half of the movie as it got
towards its Target everything slowed
down this happened most notably at the
alternate Sarah Connor's house and then
when the T800 got Sarah in his sights at
the club camo talked about how this was
employed to add tension and build off
what had come before to make Sarah feel
like she was a more danger it's the same
thing here too with it later being used
when the T800 comes face to face with
Sarah instantly it builds off the back
of those movies and reminds you of the
fear that the characters felt when
facing off against him now the illusion
that the T-1000 is the good guy
immediately drops with them killing an
innocent bystander who just so happened
to be there Aloha the can he's holding
explodes and and is it just me or could
anyone else deal with a delicious
delicious Pepsi right now we might go
get one anyway the two machines duke it
out and they actually paid a very close
attention here to how machines would
operate normally when you're crafting a
movie you tend to mask some of the
sounds with what's known as fight vocals
where you have two characters making
quips as they battle back and forth yeah
though they're both machines and thus
they don't have that Human Side to them
so whenever the pair fight they just
stay completely silent now Ani is then
thrown through a store and he crashes
out a window this actually references
the first film when he got shot up at
the club and Cameron uses the same
position and angles here to reference a
prior work in both versions the two
stand up and then walk back through the
window and I loved seeing these moments
playing side by side you also get a
great shot when the T-1000 stares at a
silver mannequin of course foreshadowing
how he looks later on now he cut the
John starting up the bike and they had
to do another take on this because
Patrick was running so fast he actually
managed to catch up to it jacking a
truck and throwing the man out this of
course mirrors ourani did it in that
first film also a little thing you might
notice as Ani pulls out is that we can
see one of the cars is already smashed
up before it crashes indicating a couple
of takes anyway Jon makes it to the
aqueduct which is when the truck pops
down and the windows on the front of it
then smash out however in the next cut
back to it we see the T1000 driving
along with the glass still there in
place now this is something a Cameron
actually went back and fixed for the 4K
release with a glass no longer smashing
out when the truck hits the ground they
also did some digital face replacement
with Ani as well and in the senior ride
SEPTA Jordan we can clearly see it as an
Arnie however they swapped it out for
the newer versions of the film but still
that 4K version made don't waste your
money now one of the coolest things that
Ani does is how he reloads the shotgun
and this was actually not to how it's
done in True Grit I loved seeing him
drop in here as he comes flying in to
save John and it sort of becomes like a
big superhero moment anyway the truck
crashes and then blows up which is when
we see the T1 thousand Street form for
the first time this also shows us that
fire can make it lose its true shape
foreshadowing that extreme Heat's away
to take it down now if you were alive in
the 90s then you'll probably remember
seeing this scene every other week
because it was used in pretty much every
visual effects documentary ever had on
TV now John gets a T800 to stop the bike
and then he inspects the bullets which
is when we get a nice little bark in the
background signaling he's a machine
foreign
John decides during his first appearance
and from here he watches they pull over
to a phone booth really nice little bit
of continuity here is that we can see
two guys in the back getting out their
car and after the phone call this is who
John taunts now John's suspicious over
the fact she's being nice and in the
background we can hear the dog barking
where are you the T800 takes over and
gives a fake name for the dog which is
what ends up tipping him off that both
of them are dead hey Janelle what's
wrong with Wolfie I can hear him barking
the dog's name is actually Max but Arnie
gives the name wealthy which was named
after Cameron's real life dog the dog
itself actually appeared in the original
movie and it was the one that showed her
about the tiki Motel now this seems
interesting because it's the only time
the two Terminators talk to each other
and they're of course both pretending to
be somebody else the scene is so cool
and the reveal is absolutely incredible
I love how she just kind of does
something off-screen to stop the dad
from talking when we get the reveal and
then the shifting of the arm it really
shows you how dangerous that this
machine is now when the blades
outstretched we can see it's got a
double edge to it and this is the same
as the blade that the character just
used to cut vegetables with morphing
back into the policeman this effect
still holds up and it's while this is
amazing more than 30 years later when
you have certain films released by last
week that don't hold up today now the
morphing effect was first introduced in
what I believe was Willow but Cameron
knocked it out the park here in terms of
how it looks also I think one of the
things about this movie and why it's
aged so well is that the stuff we're
seeing here is a problem that we face
today defects are everywhere and we've
hit a point now where you can
realistically replicate someone's face
and also their voice at the moment this
is restricted to the internet but in the
future we may get machines that can walk
around and do it Cameron said he made
this because there's no form of
technology that hasn't been weaponized
and hey it really really makes you think
now in the extended edition we see the
T-1000 moving through John's room
running his hand over things looking for
faults and breaks he discovers his
belongings holding his stuff from Sarah
and this is why he knows to then go to
her next stealing a clip Sarah is able
to pick herself free and Jun decides to
then go and break her out we get such a
creepy scene where the custodian licks
her face but she sits there playing
possums so that she can make it out now
it's John we can kinda hear his voice
breaking throughout these moments and
they actually had to redouble a lot of
his lines because it changed throughout
filming hey God damn it what's your
problem God damn it
helps this does not help our mission
later on in the desert he looks
noticeably younger and this is because
they filmed that first and then did the
other scenes later either way he gets
the Terminator to swear not to kill
anyone which only was a bit annoyed
about when he first read this script him
and Cameron compromised and said that he
could shoot people in the legs which is
what happens when they arrive at the
hospital entrance really nice attention
to detail here too and ten minutes later
when they escape you can still catch the
guy rolling on the floor speaking of
flaws I loved seeing the T-1000 Rise Up
from one and it can't be overstated how
much this blew people's minds in 91.
nothing like this had ever been seen
before and you can see why people still
talk about the movie today now another
thing that this film does brilliantly is
that it uses doubles to great effect and
it doesn't seem like there's any split
screening involved films had attempted
this in the past but it always looks
slightly off whereas here the entire
thing seems completely seamless this is
also the case with the two Sarahs later
on but there was a neat little trick
that Cameron used here the two guards
are actually Twins and Linda Hamilton's
one two so her sister was just brought
in to film these extra scenes in shut
later on they have a bit where they cut
the t800s head open and then spin around
to show the chips sitting right inside
it this is done with the mirror actually
being fake and the dummy having its head
to the back of us whilst Arnie sat on
the other side John's on one side whilst
the standings on the other and Leslie
Hamilton's also on the scene too so it
just it just works really well Leslie
letter appears in the dream sequence
when the nukes hit the park and we can
catch Sarah wearing the same uniform
that she had in the first film because
Linda was so jacked at the time it would
have stood out slightly so they got a
sister in to play the younger version of
her now another great little detail
comes when the T-1000 knocks on the
glass when the God first knocked it
didn't really make a noise whereas when
the machine does it we get a metallic
clanging
it stalks the corridors and I love how
we have the extra layer of tension when
Sarah hides from the guard because we
know it's there to kill her using
Silverman as a hostage she manages to
make away pretty far and we see just how
resourceful that Sarah is compared to
that first film she's using brooms or
whatever she can get her hands on and
snapping keys and locks to stop people
following her she comes face to face
with the Terminator though which sends
her sprinting down the hall and the T800
just stands there until Jon tells it to
help this is because it's automatically
set just to protect him and it's only
when he instructs it that it starts to
operate otherwise we also know from the
first film that it doesn't know what
Sarah looks like and thus it wouldn't
know it's her until Jon says it's his
mother now down the hall we actually get
quite a nice thematic reversal to the
prior film in that Arnie started out by
looking human but as is more machine
side was exposed he ended up donning
sunglasses however this subconsciously
made us distance ourselves from him as
it's more difficult to connect with
someone if you can't see their eyes the
sunglasses are smashed at this point
revealing on his eyes so you have him
losing them as he becomes more human
huge shout outs to Robert get for
pointing that out and it makes this
movie a sort of reverse of the first at
the midpoint both the machines either
lose or gain their glasses depending on
if they become more or less human-like
now at this point the T-1000 arrives
zombie watches it moves through the bars
love the little bit where the gun gets
stuck in it and it just shows the
machine like thinking that it possesses
Dr Silverman Witnesses and we know that
come T3 that this kinda messed him up he
got back on the right track but I love
how at least he knows he's wrong even if
he did kind of have to lie to himself as
he got further down the line at this
point they make it at the car park and
Sarah holds up a vehicle which is when
Arnie gets in and drives Sarah could
have easily been the one sat in the
driver's seat but instead they have a
shooting whilst the T800 man's the
steering wheel this is because if the
T800 gets shot then it can easily keep
driving whereas if Sarah's hit then she
might crash the car this scenes
brilliant and it shows how Relentless
the T-1000 is with it still giving Chase
even when it's [__] up morphing back
together we get more foreshadowing for
the end and also watches on he turns the
lights out again tying back to that
night vision anyway at this point they
pull into a petrol station and if you
look at the gas tanks you can catch a
little symbol this actually belongs to
benthic petroleum who were the company
that popped up in the abyss now the
extended version has a scene where they
switch only from read only to learning
mode and Skynet actually disabled this
so Terminators were slaves with it being
AI if they got to a certain point they'd
of course want to do their own things
however this keeps them locked in
instead of thinking for themselves or
that this allows him to question and
adapt and it sets him on the path to
become even more human Acero almost
smashes the chip but Jon puts her off
doing this and they then drop it back in
without telling it what happened however
the machine asks if there was a problem
even though to it it should have lasted
a split second as we can see though
there's an elapsed time counter in its
vision in tipping it up to something
being amiss stuff like this is built
into all computers which is why even
when you turn your laptop off it still
keeps the correct time now outside we
watch as they steal a car which is
stunner by only smashing his hand right
through the window he doesn't clear the
glass out and instead just sits down
because sitting on Glass isn't going to
hurt him along the way they stop at a
place that's called Cactus Jacks which
is another one of Arnie's very first
films John starts to tell Arnie how to
act like a human and we get some father
and some moments where they both learn
from each other Cameron later had the
pair fixing up a car together because
fixing things is how a lot of people
Bond General suggest is that Humanity
doesn't have a chance because it's in
our nature to turn against each other
and this is actually what happens when
skynet's put in charge given full
military access and possessing a perfect
flight record the AI slowly slotted into
every single outlet firing upon Rush air
they know the Russians will fire back
and I'll hate for each other leads to
our own undoing cut across to Miles
Dyson at work and a nice little detail
on the monitor has some tape saying bit
happens out in the desert the group then
go off the grid and what's Wild is they
could have laid low here without ever
getting caught it's Sarah's need to stop
Dice and that pulls them back into The
Fray and had they just stayed here they
might be okay now I do kind of feel like
the film slows down quite a lot here but
that might just be because I tend to
watch the extended version instead of
the theatrical one either way it allows
Jon and the Terminator to bond with each
other and also allows Sarah to have her
own plot as well it's also an Oni asks
John to explain why people cry which of
course plays in that amazing ending now
there's a great little bit where the
Terminator high fives John and being so
powerful it of course makes him regret
like watching this video when you're
supposed to have plans today I'm just
kidding yeah you had nothing going on
which which is why you're here so thanks
I guess and that Oni also gives a thumbs
up which is the last thing he does when
being dropped into the smelter and if
you don't give the thumbs up it'll be
the last thing you do now in inspired by
her nightmare she heads out after Dyson
and the Final Act of the movie is pretty
much in opposite to the first that had
things set on a cause and effect Loop
whereas this says that you can actually
alter the future seems like it all might
be stuck though as Sarah misses the shot
and this is Judah miles's son
distracting him from work it's sort of
like how things stopped Sarah and John
getting killed but they do of course
eventually alter things later on Sarah
says
I love you John
I always have and this is an article
Reese in the first film I love you
I always have the arm scene happens
which you can't we can't show cause a
bloody demonetization but this is Left
Behind once more in the gear during the
third act originally we were then going
to close out on it with us getting focus
on it and this would mean that things
would still play out the same further
down the line a novelization would spell
out that genre back to throw it in but
for whatever reason this didn't make it
to the screen obviously Hollywood
currently this franchise alone though
but it's interesting to imagine how it
kept things the same now after the
silent alarm is tripped everything's
locked down and there's only has to
blast its way through using a grenade
launcher grabbing gas masks they have to
wear these to cover for the gas system
and they also come in handy later on
when the SWAT team fire tear gas now
because of these gas masks Yeah we
actually miss an appearance by a little
actor when the SWAT team come in they
have to wear them too and one of these
guys is played by my man D Norris you
probably recognize Norris is playing
Hank in Breaking Bad and he also starred
alongside Awning in Total Recall the
T800 also has a big grenade belt
strapped around it and when the sword
team show up they do a cool thing with
the costume he ends up spinning it
further down so the grenades are under
his arm and this is so they're less
likely to get hit and blow up along with
him he also shoots at the police using a
minigun and this is the same model the
character Duke used in Predator which of
course starred Arnie taking the arm and
making the way out miles stays behind
after being hit and this helps them by
making the SWAT Retreat years earlier
Joe Morton actually had a collapsed lung
and he said he used his hyperventilating
during that to inform his performance
here attacked by all the police the T800
skin starts to cut away and I love how
he uses non-lethal means to take
everyone out this includes removing gas
masks and shooting people with grenades
because they need to travel a certain
distance before they can detonate future
leads to globnam on Reddit as well for
pointing out that we also get a great
bit of text when we see the terminator's
vision in the bottom right you can see
two lines that say termination override
and this is due to the promise that the
machine made to John the T-1000 was up
and manages to get to the chopper and he
says
get out
this is building off the back of the
first film when Arnie said the same
thing
get out flying under a freeway they of
course had to do this for real and
though they tried with CGI it just
didn't look good bony some studios
realized that CGI didn't look good and
they did for real now the helicopter
pilot pulls off some amazing moves here
and it really feels death defying when
you watch it play out as for how the
character did it we get some shots to
him piloting the chopper and in a
split-second moment you can catch a cool
detail because the T-1000 has to Fire
and reload he has a third hand that's
piloting the craft chasing them down in
a truck carrying liquid nitrogen the
T800 climbs on top of the cab in order
to take it down properly again they had
to do this for real and it's reasons
like this why the movies aged so well
spilling liquid nitrogen everywhere the
T-1000 is frozen and they use an actual
amputee to pull up this effect seemingly
destroyed it rises Like a Phoenix from
the fire but the extended edition shows
that it's caused catastrophic damage we
get moments where it glitches out and
gets stuck to the environment and even
its luck never fully lines up as it
walks in you might notice the top half
of it's the policeman's uniform whereas
the bottom still has the biker clothes
from before they really do a CGI Master
Class here and have a number of
different effects in place and I'm
surprised they actually managed to come
up with on the first score of this
technique the T-1000 morphs so its face
flips when it's pushed into a wall and
it also gets punched in the head and
then turns it into hands normally
someone will come up with an effect like
this and then it's the next one where
they'll think about what else to do but
this shows how creative Cameron and Stan
Winston got on their first go Sarah
sends Jon aways the machine closes in
now we see she stumbles whilst loading
up the shotgun she drops a shell on the
floor which you get a clear focus on and
this actually pays off in the final
takedown Sarah is shooting the machine
back towards the boiling hot pit but the
gun runs out of bullets just as it's on
the edge Aji managed to load this then
it would have been fine and she'd not
have needed to wait for Arnie to save
the day either way the T-1000 steps are
in the shoulder and says
I know this hurts and as we know I've
detailed files on human anatomy the
T-1000 still mimics Sarah however the
glitch causes it to beat them up into
the floor which then gives it away
arriving just in time the machines taken
down and we watch as it goes through
morphing into all those it's been before
Boston mother even has the blades used
in the kitchen and this was another
scene that stays stuck in my mind just
watching its face turn into a screaming
mouth it it's all so well done and they
actually use recordings of Cameron
screaming as the machine cried out in
pain
unfortunately there's one chip left and
this exists inside the terminator's head
getting a handshake from Sarah and
saying goodbye this scene might have
made this unfeeling hard here get a
little pain Sarah presses the factory
remote to lower it down and this is a
similar button and device to what she
pressed at the end of the first film my
boy goes out giving a thumbs up and for
the Skynet version we see the pair
living peacefully in the future there's
no need to make several different
sequels to the point where you try and
make a Terminator 2 sequel like seven
different times CGI Jon Connor is not
killed by CGI Arnie and everyone gets to
live happily ever after Michael Jackson
turned 40. okay and we got Sarah's
granddaughter now playing in the park
Sarah records a message much like the
ending of the first film now we close
out on this excellent movie and that
concludes Terminator 2 Judgment Day
really hope you enjoyed this video and
huge thank you for all your support been
incredible watching so many you guys
sign up as members to the channel we've
just hit the 100 mark and it helps us
make classic movie breakdowns instead of
being so reliant on newer films if you
want to support the video then please
click the join button below and look
even if you don't mate I'm gonna give
you guys a choice so Inception will be
our next classic movie breakdown and
then we're tackling the babadook but
then after then it's up to you we can
either continue with the Terminator and
then go on to three or jump back to
aliens and do alien resurrection I'm
also itching to do Exorcist 3 and I also
want to talk about the Blair Witch
Project because it just it just scared
me as a kid so yeah let me know what you
guys want to see and if you missed our
first Terminator video then that's
linked on screen right now hopefully see
you over there right after this and
without the way I've been Paul you guys
have been the best especially if you
made it to this point I'll see you next
time you take care peace